ein dankeschön hat die familie nach
hause
zu hause können wir hier stark sein für
österreich
danke eine familie in partnern geliebten
menschen dass wir stark sein damit wir
stark für österreich sein können
danke an meine familie dass wir stark
sagt am endlich stark fürs treu sein
kann
danke an die familien partner und
gelingt menschen das hier stark sein
damit wir stark österreich sind dank an
die familie freunde und partner das hier
stark sein damit wir stark für
österreich sein können danke an unsere
familienangehörigen dass wir stark und
wir stark in österreich sagt er noch
vielen dank an die familie partner und
geliebt menschen dass wir stark sein
werden